ja ich begrüße ganz herzlich zur
heutigen sitzung und wir gehen heute
noch mal auf die gestalt der letzten
sitzung ein
zwar ist das dieser mitte her wir sind
sie noch mal wieder heißt die richtig
harten wird johann gottfried herder und
er hatte eine sehr interessante theorie
zum tretbecken das war sehr interessant
also dazu gesagt hatte machen wir mal
ein bisschen wiederholung das sommer
machen und blick auf die letzte sitzung
ich fast so ein bisschen zusammensetzen
können gerne korrigieren sie können
gerne sagen ob der kunde punkte haben
die ihnen hier besonders frauen
aufgefallen sind dürfen sie gerne sagen
also zunächst mal denke ich kann sagen
also her da hat das ganze ganze theorie
der triebe in einem theologischen
kontext entwickelt das heißt schöpfung
er spricht vielleicht auch noch
natur aber ein artist schöpfung das
ergebnis eine instanz bot ein größeren
kontext der diese schöpfung verursacht
das muss man also dieses setting hat ist
also generelle in der rallye
konstellation ist die schöpfer dann sagt
er
die schöpfung ist triebhaft strukturiert
sie ist mehr gespür heimisch sie ist
technologisch also verziehen hin
ausgerichtet und diese zielrichtung die
verläuft nach einer grundform als eine
form und diese form die klärt sich mit
zunehmender komplexität immer mehr
hoffen
vielleicht erinnern sie sich noch hier
an diese stufe folge was war dann
nachher ganz unten in dieser dynamik ist
in sich noch ich hatte hier ganz unten
handlichen geschrieben
betriebe sollten sie sich vielleicht
noch
und dann hatte ich das ganze ist ein
bisschen aufgebaut also ich hatte hier
betriebe und die trieb basis könnte man
sagen es war das gemacht und hatte hier
sind teil hoch und jetzt hatte ich hier
hatten wir gesehen gibt es um die erste
entwicklungsstufe
genau aus stahl und dann kamen sie uns
schon gesagt wichtig kristalle kristalle
dann die metalle und wie hatte man das
genannte zusammen die das war eine die
fallende die gruppe der das des
anorganischen genau sowas kann danach
ein gemüse
also dass die pflanzen und was dann noch
darüber
die tiere dann ganz oben natürlich der
mensch von ihr bezahlt das problem hier
das ist praktisch für das organische
organisches oder lebewesen und abstrakt
lebewesen pflanzen sind ja auch
lebewesen wie sie wissen war das ganze
eher dass wir die noch ein bisschen
geschieden so ein bisschen an die
aristotelische seele lehre wer von ihnen
kennt ins westfälische sälen werden also
jetzt natürlich nicht mehr organischen
geld gibt es keine seele wäre als der
schnitt müsste hier gemacht werden die
pflanzen dass die sogenannten air seele
da
ok genau 1 ergo ein werk also ein zweck
so könnte man sehen war es thomas gibt
es diese sehen leere dass es dem einmal
diese mehr die näher sehen dass andi
pflanzen haben nunmehr die gehen auf
mehr stoffe müssen sich ernähren durch
wasser durch photosynthese pilze ist die
freude in vielen fallen pilze machen
hier keine photosynthese das heißt es
sind keine pflanzen aber sie sind
trotzdem pflanzen ähnlich dann gibt es
die wahrnehmung des dem wahrnimmt und
serienteilen das ist ein die tiere
man könnte sich jetzt allerdings vorher
nicht auch pflanzen waren nehmen können
die moderne wissenschaft gibt auch
gewisses zensuren und dann gibt es
natürlich neben dem wahrnehmen den teil
auch noch denen das würde den menschen
zusätzlich zu dem lehrenden und den
warmen seen den sälen stufe müsste mit
dem messer genommen sagen
ja genau die logos die denkende seele
der denkende das entscheidende play
sie entscheidet dann der menschen das
ist so ein top aus diesem dreieck
niederungen zwischen pflanzen tieren
nicht jetzt ist aber das problem
folgendes der mensch ist doch eigentlich
auch in tieren also schauen sie mal
anthropologie biologie homo sapiens
menschenaffen
wir sind eigentlich ein ganz ganz
spezifischer menschenaffen das heißt
eigentlich müsste man hier streng
genommen müsste man hier ja so ein
bisschen mehr sein
einheiten machen beziehungsweise und
bestimmte tier familie und das ist das
da ist die spannung bei her da angelegt
her da spricht einmal auch von mensch
als tieren also einem ganz besonderen
tieren dann aber wiederum setzte den
mensch dem tier ein bisschen entgegen
das wollte auf wollte sie nur hinweisen
und es gibt ebenso eine ganze richtung
eine zielrichtung technologie kann die
mannschaft ein bisschen ist ein bisschen
die das zählt alles da oben hin ab dass
die tellyou.de los ist das ziel eine
teleologische wird und das ganze geht
nach einer form und er sagt diese form
die findet ihr menschen den höchsten
ausdruck also nicht dass die form im
menschen an komplexesten ist das die
form komplexer wird sind die form wird
nur klar deutlich
ich freue mich immer dieselben zu
gründen
wissen sie noch jemand diese theorie
event das ist immer dieselbe form zu
grunde wie manch ein bisschen deutlicher
manchmal weniger dort die sind diese
position die wir haben
position genau das ist der gegensatz
dazu nochmal die genese gemacht
informationstheorie börse city gewesen
und jetzt war das interessante dass er
die genese bedeutet dass sich die form
mit zunehmender entwicklung
verkompliziert sich sein entfaltet wie
so maaßen aber dass die form am anfang
der anträge ist und dass sie viel
differenzierter das können sie
beispielsweise bei der imperialen
entwicklung verfolgen der differenziert
sich und arbeite weiter reform aspekte
mit hinzu und die moderne
evolutionstheorie wir sicherlich wir im
sinne der genese zu verstehen als die
konfigurations theorie obwohl in der
zeit der aufklärung die pre formation
szenerie dominant vereinzelt ist ja
jetzt spricht er davon dass zehn sich
noch dass die pflanzen was was was neben
die pflanzen im sich auf die pflanzen
nehmen auch anorganisches und zwar waren
dass es waren so salze und sie sehnen
sich
man spricht ja von salzkristalle
seitdem wirkt es da dass zu geben das
heißt die pflanzen nehmen diese sachen
auf um überhaupt leben zu können aber
man kann jetzt nicht sagen dass eine
pflanze oder auch ein mensch nur eine
summe mehr additiv für summe aus diesen
bestandteilen ist eine pflanze ist ja
nicht nur salz und wasser und sonst
machen also sind die pflanze die
transformiert diese ganzen elemente wir
haben einmal gesagt sich hebt sie auf
gewissermaßen wie genau soll es
natürlich auch mit den menschen und den
tieren mit einigen jedenfalls die
pflanzen essen es gibt ja tiere die
nicht pflanzen essen und nicht bevorzugt
löwen zum beispiel die fressen lieber
menschen oder andere tiere und der
mensch sofern nicht ein vegetarier oder
veganer ist der ist auch andere tiere
das heißt dieses stoffes setzte sich
ineinander und diesen konvertibel aber
so dass sie höher
eine höheren einheit an ein ding also
wenn der mensch ein tier ist dann
verarbeitet er dieses kunden diese
stoffe aber nicht so dass da jetzt
irgend was sie zukommt so hebt das ganze
eher sublimiert sozusagen ein stoff und
das finde ich ganz interessant dass hier
also her da selbst von einer
transformation in höhere lebensformen
das ist also sehr modernen tanz
formation lebens frau total im trend
gerade der begriff sublimierung habe ich
jetzt eingeführt werden aufhebung könnte
man auch sagen
natürlich ganz voraussetzung von der
begriff an hegel genau darauf wollte
sich in bildung und herausbildung davon
spricht dass selbst eine herausbildung
der form da haben also bildung drin weil
die pflanzen die nehmen die die
kristalle auf und bilden sie hinauf die
tiere fressen die pflanzen und bilden
damit die pflanzen hinauf der mensch ist
manchmal tiere und bildet damit die
tiere irgendwie hinauf und sich so muss
man sich das vorstellen also ein sehr
geordnetes sehr gerichtet das modell von
haben sie noch andere fragen
[Musik]
das ist ein guter ist ja schauen sie
jetzt ja natürlich die pflanze kann man
sagen fressen ja fleischfressende
pflanzen als manche pflanzen die die
fressen auch tiere und vielleicht sogar
auf menschen oder gibt es pflanzen die
menschen fressen
bestimmt würde er das so sagen aber er
würde dann nicht sagen dass irgendwie
dass guter punkt ich glaube nicht dass
er sagen würde dass der mensch dann
sublimiert wird ist das wäre ja zu einem
wieder geputzt
es wären seine wiedergeburt theorie hat
seine sonne gibt es ja auch sein krad
und chrysler aus theorie dass also alles
wieder so ein kreislauf geht das macht
er glaube ich nicht ein zyklisches
modell für hertha ist wie sie vielleicht
auch gesehen haben auch dieser dieses
ziel hier was sind das ziel überhaupt
dass menschen das ist das ziel hier
sollte erreichen
was ist das ziel der transformation das
höchste ziel ja genau humanität und was
ist humanitäre ist die menschlichkeit
und sich die menschheit sind die
menschlichkeit
was ist denn das humanität versteht das
daran erkennen wie man sagt das war
jetzt unmenschlich also das war nicht so
dass es den eltern um zurückzukommen
also dem kleinen wesen das zweck des
menschen entspricht also mensch das wäre
es im normativer begriffe von menschen
menschheit ist kein verstanden werden
biologisch als eine kategorisierung
terminus klasse familie art homo sapiens
das ist aber nicht normativ normativ
meint da ist keine werte verbunden
das einfach eine klassifikation es gibt
menschen es gibt pflanzen es gibt
irgendwelche anderen haben und das ist
nun zugehörigkeit verhältnis menschlich
kalten gehen bis normativ ermittelte
sein
es ist dasjenige was der mensch was die
menschheit erreichen so gut so sie
überhaupt da ist das ass existenz zweck
es ist also letztendlich für hertha die
moralität also mobilität könnte
vielleicht eine freiheit mit hinzu jetzt
ist aber so das ist natürlich verhindern
eine zwischenstation entziehen sich ja
sagt hier geht es noch weiter
da gibt es noch ein zweites reichen
pro forma aber nicht weiter eingehen wir
bleiben hier nur in diesem diesen sagen
nun haben ehrt bereich ansetzen
[Musik]
bei tieren also bei nichtmenschlichen
tiere meinte es ist ganz interessant
ich kann ich kann sie da verweisen auf
die zusammenfassung meines letzten
gestrigen seminar super tierethik habe
ich ein buch gesprochen von dem thomas
so dem dorf topologie zu dem dorf und
der ein buch geschrieben das heißt
beginnt also die kluft wer sich
interessiert kann mich an schreiben oder
so finden auch auf die lokals die
zusammenfassung der gäste sitzen in
diesem buch begibt entspricht dieses
thema an das zwischen menschen und nicht
menschlichen tieren eine kluft zu
existieren scheint also eine ganz große
kluft von der auch er daher so ein
bisschen ausgeht und jetzt sagt aber
sittendorf es gibt so eine art
entsprechung von moralität bei tieren
das war ja das was sie meinten alle
nichtmenschlichen tieren diese
entsprechung dass es nach süden dorf
empathie empathie und beim menschen ist
die partie zwar auch vorhanden
auch wir menschen sind mitleids führt
aber wir haben noch die fähigkeit zu
abstrahieren von der empathie und sie zu
objektivieren im sinne von moral
gesetzen und rechts rechts gesetzt
das heißt wir können uns davon
distanzieren aber es gibt eine gewisse
entsprechung und es wären das dorf bei
manchen tiere bewegen wo man natürlich
nicht gegenüber haben
aber stimmt tanzen haben sich ja nicht
mit salz gefüllt
das war eine stimme sprechen empathie
oder einfühlungsvermögen vielleicht ein
bisschen neutraler gesetzt und der
mensch nach suppe dorf und nach der
transformiert diese empathie dieses
mitgefühl im sinne der abstraktion hin
zu einem system der mobilität ein system
von gesetzen von rechten die gar nicht
mehr mit unserem empfinden zu tun haben
ob ich jetzt mit meinem zimmer oder
nicht ist für die rechtsordnung völlig
soll das tun darauf haben wir uns
geeinigt
aber sie sagen zu recht es gibt gewisse
entsprechungen hier auch bei
nichtmenschliche tiere in jeder hinsicht
werden ist dieses volk entwicklung sowie
wenn mal was dann mündet in recht nicht
lediglich eine folge des zusammenlebens
der menschen und ließe sich organisieren
die frage würde man das gleich und sagen
werden fünf leute auf einer insel eben
die das weibchen vor ende
wie überhaupt nicht warten sondern nur
auf uns und empathie regen entwicklung
in einer mine im gegensatz zu entfernen
auch so etwas also ich glaube schon
ich glaube sobald wir sind zwei menschen
zu tun haben die frage ist ob das recht
die moral gibt wenn wir es nun mit einem
menschen oder eine person zu tun wenn es
nur eine person gebe nur einen menschen
ob dann ein rechtssystem entwickelt
werden können dabei wäre ja keinen kein
inters objektivität mehr da diese sonst
nottwil ich musste mich ja zu mir nicht
moralisch verhalten bei dem ich komme
mit mir eigentlich selben konfliktseiten
steht zufrieden aber es kann man sich
fragen
das stimmt ja das stimmt richtig richtig
guter punkt hören aber auch die tiere
ampel an wenn sie mit einem urlaub
losgeht
wir haben gesetze gebildet ich glaub's
nicht reichen gibt es mit sicherheit es
gibt ein leitwolf und es gibt bestimmte
position aber diese gesetz das sind
keine gesetze weil gesetze müssten immer
formuliert sein denkt sie an die zehn
gebote das kein gewohnt gesetze müssen
letztendlich niedergeschrieben oder
zumindest bewahrt wenn auch über
generationen hinweg oder über individuen
hinweggesetzt sind nur an gesetze wenn
es eine gewisse über individuelle
geltung haben wenn sie qualifiziert sind
und solche verhalten strukturen die
durchaus recht stabil sind
die müssen dies wären immer wieder neu
verhandelten laden werden dass der life
ball von jüngeren stärken wolf getötet
wird dann ist der das ändert sich ganz
schnell aber sie haben natürlich recht
es gibt die man irgendwie einen eine
leitfigur und die bestimmt das dann für
eine bestimmte zeit aber es hat lange
nicht diese allgemeinheit diese
objektivität wie gesetze ali wird hier
nicht vom gesetz entsprechen aber von
gewissen strukturen oder orden und da
sehen sie für die richtig teuren tiere
gibt es gewisse ordnungen gewisse
struktur und die dann eben beim menschen
eher noch viele objektive abstrakter
qualifizierter wäre
gewisse entsprechen aber es ist richtig
dass ich darauf verweisen
es gibt gewisse analogien oder
entspricht das deutet auch darauf hin
dass hier sind entwicklungs continum
gibt es keine sprünge ergebnis also
wieder die frage wie sieht es mit diesem
geld aus es ist ein qualitativer sprung
zwischen menschen und nicht menschen von
tieren qualitativen oder quantitativen
debatte aber sie sehen
rechts und 60er jahren der wert
die menschen sind rechts rechts bringt
deshalb intensiv nicht angesetzten sich
kennen wir haben nicht sondern sie
orientieren sich an der zunahme der das
soziale gewissen kennengelernt haben und
ob das auch gesetze oder nichtsein für
uns besonders dass beide volk gebracht
werden und wird man feststellen dass
normale mensch hätte ich keine gesetz
kennt sie keine gesetze der inhalt nicht
und deswegen 140 auch nicht angesetzt
sondern orientiert sich daran wie in der
berufung von wölfen oder regulierungen
getroffen worden sind nach der
verpflichtung nach dem gedanken folgt
ist ein unvergesslich werden wollen
die musik die einzelnen auch rechts
springt anders halten und wir sind
gezählt werden
ich glaube der wolfsrudel ist ist ein
guter begriff sie kennen alle thomas
haupt die lupus den menschen ist der
mensch und wolf hat er ist sicherlich
was dran
aber schauen sie irgendwann kommt er mit
dem gesetz in konflikt wir können dich
tun was wir wollen irgendwann spät ich
will jetzt keine beispiele geben aber
irgendwann kommen wir mit dem gesetz in
konflikt steuerbetrug falschparken
schwarzfahren und so weiter irgendwann
kann man seine individuelle freiheit
nicht mehr weiter aussehen waren dann
notwendigerweise konfiguriert und man
konnte damit etwas über individuelle
struktur die man vernünftigerweise auch
akzeptieren müsste gesellschaftsvertrag
als es endlich gibt es sondern haben ein
besseres selbst und uns trotz unserem
wölfischen selbst gibt es ein besseres
höheres selbst in uns sagen viele die
einsehen dass es schon sinn von uns dass
diese rechtsnorm gibt weil werden alle
nämlich der akten was sie wollten
würde sie ein riesenchaos der mensch
könnte kein wolfsrudel sein weil wenn er
das wäre dann würde es sich gegen die
wände der mensch braucht
ordnerstrukturen aber ich gebe ihnen
durchaus recht dass es gewisse gefahr
bereiche gibt wo es wo der mensch sich
eben gerade nicht am recht orientiert
aber das heißt da habe ich nicht dass es
nicht insgeheim doch anerkennt auch wenn
er immer wieder bestrebt ist im gesetz
zur wieder zu kennen glaube ich jeder
von sich
aber es ist ein riesen thema und wir
müssen jetzt das jetzt leider beenden
weil jetzt müsse man nämlich übergeben
also letztes punkt bildung der humanität
das ist das ziel von
und jetzt möchte ich nämlich aus diesem
netten herrn hilder geben es ist sie
wieder heißt steht der brand aber wie
heißt mit vornamen johann friedrich
rumba und 30 haben sie auch den text
bekommen haben sie gelesen ja also ich
fand das war ein ganz während er noch
nicht die texte filme bekommt nicht mehr
verteidigen ist schreiben sie mir
einfach eine e mail an nehme ich sie
auch also dieser texte ist da muss ich
dazu folgendes sagen dieser text damit
nicht sehr froh ich bin auch durch lagen
nach langer recherche auf diesen text in
lateinischer schrift gestoßen
normalerweise gibt es diese schrift die
heißt von bildungs treten die gibt es
eigentlich nur in frakturschrift
vorlegen und das wäre für ein gemüse
dass dazu zu lesen und für mich auch
weil ich hätte das gar nicht auf die
folgen machen können also mit jetzt als
bilddatei auf die vor ihm haben können
aber nicht hinsetzen im sinne der
bearbeiten haben da zeit und ich habe es
in einer internet auf der internetseite
gefunden ich kann ihnen das verlinken
da finden sind auch ganz andere
schriften von wohn war er hat also
diesen kerngedanken den in diesem werk
wird es für heute lesen formulierten hat
er in zwei weiteren publikationen
ausgebaut
dieser texte wie heute lesen der hat ein
original glaube ich nur 20 bis 30 seiten
und haben nun sechs seiten
geschickt habe aber sie wissen
frakturschrift war immer größer das
heißt habe mehr raum gebracht um die
zähne dazu führen und diesen sechs fand
ich ungemein interessant und wir wollen
heute diesen text lesen uns fragen wie
blumenbach wird bildungsträger den jesus
formativ es stimmt und wie sich diese
theorie von blumenbach zu derjenigen von
hertha verhält und dann wahllos fragen
welche disziplinen theorie zuzuordnen
ist das ganz interessante des
wissenschafts theoretisch umbach ist
sitzt zwischen ein spiel also blumenbach
könnte der heutige technologie
bezeichnet werden als ein
wissenschaftstheoretiker das finde ich
sehr bezeichnet er könnte gelesen wird
als ein naturphilosoph und schreibe es
mir auf dass wir das alles mal haben
alle das muss ich jetzt leider hier
entfernen
das mache ich jetzt hier weg
also man kann ihn ganz verschiedentlich
seele burbach
man könnte sagen jetzt ein
naturphilosoph
das finde ich besonders spannend
wissenschaftstheoretiker
haben sie noch eine idee ihr könnte mich
noch klassifizieren seiner tätigkeit
ja
also es
wissenschaftler von menschen wie morgen
von wem genau so wie bei anthropologie
aufzählung ist ein bisschen wird aber
geologie richtig biologe sehen sich an
den polypen von dem er spricht gern zu
beginnen was noch
punkt punkt punkt an sie sehen in dieser
zeit im 18 jahrhundert war die disziplin
und nicht so ganz klar voneinander
geschieden wie sie heutzutage city hatte
ein biologe noch ganz stark
philosophisch reden können
wissenschaftstheoretiker gab es damals
noch nicht als disziplin ist sie sehen
also hier in dieser zeit da fehlt sehr
vieles noch zusammen was wir was ich
später in verschiedenen disziplinen
ausgebildet
mythologisch usw schauen sie mal wie
auch blumen was schreib ich schreib
bitte würde heutzutage ein biologe zu
schreiben was fertigen auf 1 thiele dann
die art der gattung es aus der schweiz
von 1780 schrift wie schreibt dann ist
hat sich das erinnert
genau richtig guter punkt der
schriftsteller
hmm schriften beschreibt er den
erfahrungsbericht ich verwende das wort
ich wenn sie ein mit der zeitschrift
nature oder science ein aufsatz lest
wird ganz selten das wort ich vollkommen
warum weil ich immer subjektiv klingt
und was wohl mit den naturwissenschaften
die objektivität und es ist meine
geschichte ist eine geschichte als ich
damals gelesen setzt läuft also wie ein
märchen für ungefähr zwei jahre da ich
einige ferientage auf dem lande zukunft
fand ich eine mühle wache eine artige
art grüner arm polypen die sich durch
einen langgestreckten spinde förmigen
körper und kurze meisten streifen von
der gemeinen grünen gattung auszeichnen
und mit deren wundern ich meine
gesellschaft einen teil ihrer zeit
vertreiben wird teils das warme trockene
sommer ritter noch mehr aber die
dauerhafte konstitution diese polypen
gattung begünstigte die bekannten
reproduktions versuche die wir damit
anstellten so dass die wiederbesetzung
gleichsam zusehens vonstatten zu gehen
schieden schon den zweiten dritten tag
waren den verstümmelten tieren wieder
neue arme schwänze usw angewachsen uhr
bemerkten wir immer sehr deutlich dass
die neue ergänzen können bei allen
reichlichen futter doch weit kleiner als
vorher war und ein verstörter rumpf
sowie er die verlorenen teile wieder
hervor trieb auch im gleichen maße
rechts sichtlichen ein zu kriechen und
kürzt
und stimmen zu wünschen was ist in einem
college eine buchung teilweise genau der
ganz verschiedene also produkt kann ganz
verschiedenes bedeutet das kann auch so
was bedeuten dass ein tier ist so einen
qualitativen essen art messedirektor
also wird sie dann auch schon auf
wikipedia
da habe ich das bild viel her so muss
man sich das vorstellen er spricht auch
von einem grünen ja schauen sie hier
spricht von einer grünen gattung hier ja
schon da habe ich gedacht das passt doch
sehr gut hier dieses gebiet also ich man
muss sich das so vorstellen wie hier das
abgeschnitten werden und da drei fragen
ist es nach gewachsen aber eben nicht
mehr so stark wie es noch vor
jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen
woher kommt das dass das wieder
nachwächst und zwar ähnlich nach
derselben form bist du vor und der
zimmer beim bildungsträger schon
angekommen
einige zeit nachdem ich wieder zur stadt
gekommen war musste ich einen menschen
besuchen
jetzt haben wir noch nicht disziplinen
gleich einen menschen besuchen
wer schon lange am windpark rang gelegen
hatte der schade wie wird man es heute
wenn der schade war über dem knie
getroffen
auch die gleichen teilen die wunde für
mich gefunden
aber schauen sie mal wenn er jetzt einen
mensch einen kranken menschen besucht
was ist dann auch hier arzt richtig
wurde mir diesen staaten arzt vorbei
mediziner haben wobei das muss man mit
vorsicht geniessen über dem knie und
offen und auch die weichen teile zu
einer tiefen grube aus geleitet das
besserte sich nachher aber so wie die
lücke im fleisch nach und nach wieder
mit ernährt oder nabe ausgefüllt wurde
so senkte sich auch das benachbarte
gesunde fleisch nicht gleich gerade all
gemacht wieder gleichsam zu schwinden so
dass ende die marke in der kugel und das
fleisch am rand mit dem einander fast
gleich stunden und jede nur noch eine
breite aber ziemlich flache delle macht
als mozart estland ist der gleiche fall
hier bei meinem grünen polypen aus dem
micra
also was ist jetzt zu vergleichen
genau richtig
es handelt sich dabei um lebewesen beim
menschen und bei polypen auch um
lebewesen
da gibt es wie sie wirklich solche
analogien und atis muttern ist ich habe
seitdem paar jahren einen großen teil
meiner mose auf die weiteren versuche
dieser damaligen analogen wie sie sich
sagen erfahrung verband von der gefolgt
die folgende blätter einige resultat
enthalten die sich doch am ende alle
darin vereinen
jetzt kommt das in allen belebten
geschöpfen sagt nicht lebewesen sind
geschöpfe
denken sie an diese ordnung die
rahmenbedingungen bei hertha er springt
auf und erschöpfung bei allen geschöpfen
von menschen bis zur made und von der cd
zum himmel herab das sind also die
pflanzen sozusagen schlimme ist ja pilz
das was anderes ein besonderer ein
geborener lebenslang tätiger wirksamer
trieb liegt ihre bestimmte gestalt
anfangs anzunehmen dann zu erhalten und
wenn es ja zerstört worden
womöglich wieder herzustellen das ist
eine ganz interessante these dass man
sich wieder eine morphologie all seinen
formen leere laufen
die morphologie
und in allen lebensformen liegt ein
tätiger trieb also tätiger trieb an was
mercedes bei aristoteles diese tätigkeit
für wirksamkeit das ist die energie ja
dass ich mich an meinen diese energie am
werk sein heißt es ja wirklich am berg
sein
herr gehör die energie heißt in gera ist
das ergo und das deutsche wort wäre es
damit verwandt die griechisch alt
griechisch und deutsch stellt es eben
sprachfamilie hinter europäische
sprachen und das kommt alles von einem
selben stamm
also dass am werk sein die dynamik als
eine bestimmte gestalt anfangs ganz
nehmen so jetzt stellt sich die frage
ist entscheidet muss es folgte handelt
es sich dabei immer um dieselbe form wie
er das behauptet oder unterschiedlich
auslöser sind zeitlich stellen
sogar
also ich glaube dass bezüglich jeder art
immer derselbe dieselbe form angesetzt
wird aber die formen der verschiedenen
aber völlig verschieden sind auch
evolutionär revolutionären entwicklung
nach kuba bestimmte gestalt in der serie
wie selten
woher kommt es dass diese lebewesen wer
man ihn von der form was nimmt das die
wieder dahin streben diese ursprüngliche
form aufrecht sagt diese reproduktion
was würden sie denn heute sagen als
naturwissenschaftlich gebildete menschen
es würden sie das sagen also bildung
streep ist eine entität wie demonstriert
ist ein gegenstand oder ein ding oder
was auch immer das postuliert also sagt
es gibt so was
oder er schließt aus dass muss sowas
geben um diese ganze phänomene erklären
zu können
was würde denn heute ein biologe eine
biologin dazu sagen muss sagen das war
der bildung streep gemeinde hat heilen
lassen
genau
genau also was würden sie am ende sagen
also nicht mehr bildungs trieb sondern
am ende genau aus dna einfach einbinden
thema also wie sie sagen der coach
so sieht oder so es ist programm
kein biologe das ist bekannt dass unsere
genetische ausstattung gegeben wobei
gehen und trieb wie sie ja auch sagte zu
beginn die sind sehr ähnlich entgegen
gehen kommt vom griechischen es ist
normal
also werden stehen auch seine band die
als heute wenn wir sagen wahrscheinlich
den der coach
die frage ist ob das ein wirklich
entsprechen muss als ob man wirklich
sagen kann der bildung stream ist lässt
sich eins zu eins umsetzen oder
dekonstruieren als eine dna ich glaube
nicht dass das geht
aber es ist ziemlich ähnlich ist das
programm was dahintersteht programm
versus fonds müssen auch noch so auf ein
trieb oder tendenz oder bestreben wie
man es nur nennen will der sowohl von
den allgemeinen eigenschaften der körper
überhaupt als auch von den übrigen
eigentümlichen griff organisierten
körper insbesondere gänzlich verschieden
ist
der eine der ersten ursachen aller
generation nutrition und reproduktion zu
sein scheint wenn ich hier um aller
missdeutung zuvorzukommen und um ihn von
den anderen naturkräften zu
unterscheiden mit dem namen des bildungs
triebes jesus format evans belegen damit
neuerlich schon groß genug worden ist
den blut umlaufen prediger salomo und
die evita bieli thet im meer ums
schreiben zu finden
so müsste es folgen nicht gut sein wenn
sie nicht auch zur not der ganzen jesus
von matthäus uns allen den werken aber
die generation die seit 2000 jahren
geschrieben nun zusammen zu keiner gar
kleine bibliothek angeschwollen sind
sollte heraus deutschen lassen
das will jetzt mal so
das ist die nutrition ernährung
nutrition nährstoffe
jetzt spricht er von kraft von kraft mit
von kräften
wir haben ja auch gesehen in der version
sind sind das streamen und kraft sehr
verwandt sind günstig sie an aristoteles
dünn am es ist die kraft
das ist ganz entscheidend generation die
entstehung die reproduktion die vor
pflanzen
er ist aber verschieden doch der ist
verschieden von dem eigentümlichen
kräften der organisierten club und dem
wähler von den anderen atomkraft
unterscheiden alles geht praktisch ein
zeugung streep ein ernährungs trieb ein
reproduktion streep und noch und meldung
ist oder wie verstehen sie dass er davon
spricht sie zu verstehen scheinen
am 1
aber jeweils zusammen
als es geht hier um die ordnung ist es
nur ein zusätzlicher trieb oder legte
dem zugrunde
es ist also eine spannende frage wie das
jetzt wie die sich zueinander verhalten
und am ende sagte halt er möchte halt
das auch schon bei den alten schriften
mehr und meine aussagen sich dem alten
testament auch schon
aufzeigt
doch muss ich auf diesem fall nur warnen
dass man ja nicht etwa diesen blieb mit
der wie plastik oder mit der iss
soziales oder gar mit dem chemischen
fermentation ganze expansion oder
anderen bloß mechanischen kräften die
einige zum zeugung geschäfte angenommen
haben vermengen und das überhaupt hier
weder um den namen noch um den bloßen
erweist existenz des bildungs trieb ist
sondern seine würde und seines
allgemeinen großen anteils den er an der
belebung der ganzen stadt zu tun ist
eine wahrheit die man bei allen diesen
untersuchungen nie aus den augen
verlieren darf und deren
vernachlässigung schon oft ihren
glücklichen vater der mit haben mag ist
die dass schlechterdings zeugen
ernährung und wieder ersetzen
im grunde bloße modifikationen einer und
eben derselben kraft sind die ersten
verbaut anderen unterhält und reparieren
als da haben wir jetzt hier eine sehr
schöne angestellt auf die schon zuvor
eingegangen
tun wir das jemals wieder so ein
bisschen genau hier an schauen wir uns
das vorstellen müssen also wir machen
dass man hier weg dieses schöne grafiken
und wohin eine neue
wie verstehen sie jetzt bitteschön das
verhältnis also noch mal kurz
er sprach hier von 3 generation
notrationen und reproduktion eine
generation
rotation und produktion
und wie verhält sich jetzt die der babys
format idee - von matthias im verhältnis
dazu also zeugen ernährung und
wiederbesetzung ganz oben sind lose
modifikation ein und derselben kraft
würden sie das jetzt hier anzeichen was
mache ich jetzt hier mit grafik
von jedem größeren kraft die zahlung
so würde in allen zugrunde irgendwie man
könnte sagen differenziert sich aus
würden sie besuchern der bildung streep
differenziert sich spezifiziert in
bestimmter hinsicht aus der
bildungsträger oder man könnte so sagen
die bildung der form die kann nur
dadurch gelingen wenn sowohl eine
generative kraft eine nährende kraft
eine produzierende kraft am werke sind
kann sich das mit zugkraft vektoren
vorstellen und die resultate wäre dann
gewissermaßen der bildungsträger diese
drei kraft rektoren und wenn wir die
addieren nach dem koalitions gesetz zu
begriffen ist jedes um tante als sie zum
beispiel wenn jetzt hier mal zwei kräfte
ansetzen
2 wissen sie ja nach der physik dass der
resultierende trieb resultierende kraft
die die addition kann man so sagen
wenn wir die bei dir dann
setze ich sie einfach aufeinander hin so
und dann verbinde ich den haltern mit
dem ende kommt es also könnte sagen dass
es faktisch hier bildungs wie nun
versuchen aber ich denke auf jeden fall
kann man sagen um diese produkte um
diese erneuerung der fonds hinzubekommen
die zu realisieren braucht es eben auch
zum beispiel ernährung wenn der kranke
mensch oder der polyp wenn man dem jetzt
in ärmlichen abschneiden dann kann das
sich nur dadurch wieder regenerieren das
der polit auch nahrung aussichten
das heißt der bildung streep als
subjekte ich mache mich stelle ich will
dass problematisieren es ist ein subjekt
subjekt das dahinter steht der was ist
es akteure
glaubst du dich müssen dass
problematisiert die rede von dem trio
der trägt dazu bei dass verschiedene
mittel ergriffen werden verschiedene
wege beschritten werden um diese form
wieder herzustellen dazu muss ich eben
das tier ernähren das muss nährstoffe
ganz klar in die wunde müssen nährstoffe
transportiert werden dass du musst die
hunde versorgen nährstoffe aber auch mit
mit eiweißen klebe stoffen und so weiter
damit das blut gerinnt und so weiter und
so fort
dann muss das fleisch wieder hergestellt
werden die nervenzellen müssen
aufgebracht verschickt muss wieder
drüber wachsen
die haut muss zugewachsen wir müssen
alle wissen nährstoffe ein transportiert
werden die wunde und das könnte man hier
durchaus so sehen wenn dieser not
rationen dass das eine manifestation und
könnte sein manifest
visionen des bildungs druck sein also
erscheint aus form werden der bildung
streep als solcher gar nicht direkt
letztendlich erscheint wird wir können
rückschlüsse ziehen auf den
bildungsbetrieb durch seine ausformung
die darauf letztendlich gerichtet sind
die form wieder herzustellen formen form
aufrecht zu halten und ich sorgen oder
haben sie mir andere ansichten wie
würden sie wissen genau dass eine gute
frage
gute frage
ja
nein
der bewegung finden wir auch
aber halten
gut die frage ist letztendlich die ganz
kurz gleich sind die frage ist die geht
die form des menschen verloren wenn er
eben den arm verlieren oder bleibt seine
form erhalten wenn sein leben erhalten
bleiben sprich wenn eben wie sie sind
die sagen das ganze halt die hat der
heilungsprozess stoffe aber warum muss
es dann bei polypen so dass da das
nachwachsen ist offensichtlich so dass
der pünktlich wird existiert könnte wenn
es nicht nachwachsen gut hoffentlich
während der mensch auch mit einem oder
nur ohne beide arme noch existieren kann
wenn er eben natürlich nur im kontext
ist gegeben man ihn auch versorgt
wenn ein mensch ganz alleine leben würde
wäre das sein todesurteil und sie sich
gemeldet
das ist das verhältnis des betriebes
das ist nicht nur an sich selbst ein
bisschen eingebaut wo ich sie sich
vielleicht warum gesagt ergeben dass wir
so dass es nicht mehr was heißt das
genau zwei nicht mitziehen
der rat sich der arm nicht beendet haben
die sendung wird am 10
forschungsergebnisse der bestand darin
die fingerkuppe abgefunden wird dann
wächst sie nach gleicher weise diese
auch warum weiß man auch weil an den
fingernagel wurzeln befinden sich das
ganze leben lang stellt stammzelle stand
als ich danach gefragt habe bis jetzt
spenden und weiß was sie zu tun hat
neben die anti stellt nur topfit und
gebe ihre positionen zu erzeugen und der
arm wenn er da oben stammzellen
gebraucht hätten wir dann viele gruppen
damaskus ist möglicherweise ist die
chance des raums zu komplizieren für das
alles werde oder es finden unternehmer
gut sehr gut also sehr gut da hin falls
die stammzellen stammzellforschung und
stammzellen gewinn um auf organe
künstlich nachrichten zu können genau
[Musik]
genauso muss sich fragen ist das pre
formation die leute da sind keine
weiteren kosten
genau also bezug auf das individuum
sicherlich reformation
die frage ist nur mit blick auf die
gesamte schöpfung weil ich werde richtig
verstanden hat er hat er die ts
betrieben das blick auf die gesamte
schöpfung allen lebensformen diese fonds
kulik die eben nur mehr aufgeklärt wird
in menschen ausgebildet wird also die
mehr an kontur gewinnt sozusagen es
damals aber das nicht um verschiedene
vorschläge
und er scheint aber müssen sie mir
zustimmen oder widersprechen
jetzt hier bin und man scheint für
verschiedene lebensformen verschiedene
formen anzusetzen also nicht irgendwie
den menschen als die letztgültige
aufklärung der in allen anderen
lebewesen identischen form
gute technik und prothetik ist eine ganz
einig wie die prothetik prothese ist nur
vorsätzen voraussetzen ansätzen technik
auch viele sagen auch menschen sind
mängelwesen wir haben kein fell
wir müssen alles kompensieren durch
technik wir bauen wir unsere augen nicht
gut genug sind prothesen in form von
brillen oder von ferngläsern die wir uns
vor setzt seine prozesse genau so setzen
wir uns irgendwelche mikrofone hier als
nur lautsprechern zu machen und was
genau zu sehen und zu hören
also der mensch ist ein politisches
wesen könnten uns mängelwesen aber eben
nicht nur mängel mangelhaft in diesem
sinne des verbleibens in diesem an allen
zu schätzen
dieser mangel ist wiederum selbst ein
ansporn antreten dann könnte vielleicht
auch ein mangel trieb sagen also beim
menschen wird der bildung streep
modernen gesprochen dass jetzt nicht
einfach ist der mensch gewesen
durch einen mangel an kompensation
stream ist eine kompensation bedingt
möglich entwicklung vorangetrieben
kompensierung anzusehen gerne spannend
also das sind modifikationen aus
differenzierungen dieses berühmte
erfinder beschreibt sie die wies
plasticker wie es heißt kraft
also bat sie ist diejenige kraft durch
welche in den vegetarischen körpern
alles glas jenige ausgerichtet wird
weswegen wir ihnen ein leben zu
schreiben
und aus diesem grunde habe ich sie die
wesentliche kraft dieser körper genannt
weil nämlich eine pflanze aufhören würde
an der pflanze sein wird diese kraft
genommen hat in den tieren findet sie
ebenso wohl statt mit pflanzen und alle
stars jenige passt die tiere mit den
pflanzen gemein haben hängt lediglich
von dieser kraft
das ist kaspar friedrich wolf
castro friedrich wolf ein vorläufer
einen scherenschnitt
das war damals üblich und er hat eben
hier
diese theorie von der generation der
heute wenn man seinen spekulationen das
ist nicht mehr haltbar aber ich bin
diese organellen als eine ausreichende
kraft das ist die wesentliche kraft also
dass praktisch diese kraft die das
lebewesen zu dem macht was es ist
sonst wäre es nicht mehr sehen auch die
identitätsstiftende kraft
interessant dass dieses plastik die
bildende kraft
das seinen fuß nach dem sex sollte
kaster friedrich wolf mit anderen worten
traktion ist eine allgemeine aber
unmerklich koordinierte reproduktion
hingegen eine wiederholte aber nur
partielle generation ein licht über eine
von diesen drei verbreitet würde
zuverlässig auch die anderen beiden
zugleich erhellen im wesentlichen kommen
alle die drei genannten geschäfte
entspricht auf eine zeugung ist
geschäfte miteinander bereichen der
bildung streep hat in allen reihen
gleich starken anteil nur der anlass der
diesen trieb im wirksamkeit ersetzt und
die weise wie sich seine wirkung häuser
sind in zufälligen umständen verschieden
bei der eigentlich so genannten
erzeugung der generation wird zum
beispiel ein bestimmtes reiferes alter
gehörige beschaffenheit der zeugung
werkzeuge und zeugung hälfte des wertes
samens vorhabens gesetzen aus welchen
sich der künftige mensch der künftige
mensch das junge tier oder die neue
pflanze bilden sollen so dass man sich
zur existenz eines jeden solchen
organisierten körpers eltern großeltern
und so bis zur ersten schöpfung haufen
laute ähnliche vorfahrt denken muss ohne
die das neugeschäft schlechterdings
nicht zu seiner entstehung hätte
gelangen
jetzt erwarte ich von ihnen heftigen
einspruch ist das noch haltbar was er
hier sein
laut wir sind nämlich zurück als ich
mache mal praktisch so wir machen das
jetzt mal weg so schön dass auch bisher
tut mir leid ich muss es leider jetzt
hier an daten löschen
also wieder einen schönen stift so als
der trick jetzt hier die these dass
sozusagen wir haben jetzt hier
verschiedene summerjam gibt verschiedene
lebewesen also mal zum beispiel ein
polyp oder sind sehr sehr klein
aufgelöst ein polyp und der wäre jetzt
praktisch das wäre jetzt polyp nehmen
wir mal den polypen enden
und der wäre dann aber eben gezeugt von
pur - 1 und so weiter es geht eben gegen
endlich oder wo auch immer hin bis an
den anfang
und hier haben wir jetzt mensch
und so dass genau dasselbe
was ist das problem hier genau
aber wir haben ja da unten zu raten die
koexistieren
und das ist ja genau entgegen der
evolution bei der evolution sagt ja wir
hatten hier irgendwas was auch immer und
dann haben wir aber hier solche
bewegungen hier so dass das bild der
evolution trieb erste 2
was er von bild hat ist wendig
und sogar die aktion wird als dieses
total jedenfalls habe ich jetzt auch
stehen anstatt der geburt habe ich mir
ein dass ich hier ganz stark sein muss
weil er ja von menschen spricht und ist
auch für menschen die ausstellung die
vom menschen repräsentieren und wenn er
nur von menschen redet dann hatte
wahrscheinlich öfter sozialen darüber
gewesen sind vater groß ist die frage
ich weiß es nicht
denkt daran es gibt kreuzung
neandertaler und moussa pions also ganz
komische ich weiß also man müsste aber
es gibt es mehrere
also lautet ähnliche vorfälle
sogar ich habe ja also eben hier
ich kenne mich zu wenig aus mittwoch mit
der anthropologie aber der mensch als
sie müssen sich im punkt vorstellen wo
der wo der mensch sich aus diesen
affenarten heraus entwickelt hat und er
gab es immer wieder gekreuzt usw bei
eltern kam da mal ne under thaler und
hier mal sowas keine ahnung
total komplex wir haben ja alle während
der tat wenig
das erstaunliche an dass auch wie
wichtig für uns dass wir das sagen im
nutzen hier habe ich mal gelesen haben
sie übrigens mitbekommen gestern ganz
große nachrichten
der erste aufrechte mensch kommt waren
bei daraus geworden
also ganz spannend wer also die frage
ist ob das überhaupt ob wir mit diesem
dieser menschenform verwandt weil es
könnte sein dass das an der menschen
hart war die ausgestorben ist und wir
dann doch von dem ersten aufrecht
menschen abstimmen das ist nur neben hat
irgendwie also eine art die mit uns gar
nicht direkt verwandt ist alles total
spannend
[Musik]
nicht
alles nach unten
genau da ist glaube ich unterschied zu
herden oder glaube hier ist ein gewisser
unterschied zu herr der lage war eine
grundform erkennen da ist scheint anders
so hat es eben habe ich jemanden
übersehen der sich gemeldet hatte zwar
hat es neben eine zeit gegeben wo man
diese frau pflanzenart für nicht so
schlecht allerdings notwendig gehalten
hat wo man nicht eben zur entstehung der
flöhe andere flöhe der krebse andere
krebs und der mäuse andere mäuse
voraussetzte sind wo man auch flöhe aus
urin und sägespänen krebse aus faulen
kalbsfleisch und neues aus lang und
alland unflath hervorbringt zu können
meinte diese generation eck vivo casa
weiland eine erwünschte freistaat der
unwissenheit und eine quelle und stütze
als sinnlich arten von aberglaube ist
aber schon lange dass sondern sie
gestürzt und soll fast immer nur sowie
die hexen farben und wünschelrute zu
anderen kann jena finsternis und zum
stillen triumph unserer erleuchteten
zeit genannt
von der probe aufklärung genau weiß ob
es ein topos die aufklärung ist eine
meteorologische metapher also aufklärung
ist ein 1 1 praktisch ein bild das wir
dass die leute damals eben übernommen
hatten aus dem metereologen aufklärung
bedeutet einfach wenn die wolken weichen
und die sonne dahinter zum vorschein
kommt das ist auf der die wolke zieht
weg und die wolke kommt die sonne kommt
zu pushen
eine meteorologische tapfer und das
licht geht eben immer als etwas was wir
der vernunft ja nicht der vernunft
nachdem sich zum beispiel an descartes
der von klar und bestimmt spricht klar
und das licht der vernunft nicht
verwundert das ist alles so metapher ok
alles sagt jetzt hier also es gab mal
zeiten die waren dunkel dunkle zeiten ja
auch meine anderen furcht fortpflanzungs
art angenommen wo man nicht eben immer
weiter runter ist die reihe unter von
derselben art sondern wo neben
unterschiedliches aus unterschiedlichen
hervorgekommen konnte wobei wir das
beschreibt das ist er unser heutigen
evolutionstheorie
also wenn er gewusst hätte dass die
position der jetzt zu dem dunklen
dass das mal später ungefähr die theorie
der aufklärung sein sollte weil nämlich
dass der dieser schlamm
das ist die ursuppe könnte man sagen was
der dann durch strahlung und sonstige
einflüsse von außen gewisse reputation
stattgefunden haben die da eben zu dem
thema geführt hat zu den effekten wesen
zu paket- und so weiter zu fahren ja
alle ganz interessant inzwischen scheint
es doch fast als wenn jede freilich gar
zu abenteuerlichen einbildungen des
schülers tischen stunde sind die nach
jährigen unendlich aufgeklärten
naturforscher ihrem allzeit verleitet
haben und als ob dort wohl bald eine
zeit kommen dürfte indem man freilich
jene sogenannte zeugung ausfalls ihres
sehr engen schranken zurückweisen aber
auch bei der da geht also zuversichtlich
behaupteten allgemeinheit der
fortpflanzung aus väterlichen sagen
allerdings wohl einige billige ausnahmen
zu bestehen
sich auch diese entstehungs leere manche
meinen ja die pre formations
theoretische dass der mensch zu sein
oder in der eizelle schon als kleines
menschen angelegt sein und da ist der
mensch praktisch nur dann wieder zeugen
gibt die frau über wandert ist ein
mensch völlig ausgebildet und der form
und inhalt nur noch größer das ist ja
eine mögliche reformationstag als jetzt
eine ganz starke polemik polemik aber so
eine schlamm theorie sei hier das was
wir heute ja unter der nutzung bestehen
das stichwort zuverlässig gibt es doch
erscheinungen in der geschichte der
organisierten körper mit ihren
aufklärung wieder schöner begriff
aufklärung und die ist eigentlich so
genannte ford fan sind offenbar verlässt
und wobei man mit ungleich größerer
wahrscheinlichkeit wieder zu einer art
von generalvikar wird zurückgehen und
zugeben müssen dass allerdings 0 zweiten
hälfte durch eine besondere art von
gärung oder voll ist ein bildungs trieb
erhalten und zu mancherlei freilich
einfachen oder wenn man will und
vollkommen vegetation auf schiffen nur
eine solche vegetation stadt viel
anzuführen und zwar nicht bloß schimmel
oder mode weil sich die feinde der
generation die voca duft noch immer mit
unsichtbaren luft samen und dergleichen
spitzfindigkeiten durchschlagen können
sind ein wahres gewächs an konstanz
konsistenz und farbe anderen vollkommen
vollkommen der pflanz gleich und doch
weder von seinesgleichen gezeugt noch
aus auch selbst geht sofort verschickt
nämlich auf schüsse die an allerhand
pflanzen durch den bloßen stich der
galveston verursacht werden vorzüglich
die sogenannten schlaf dags oder wie man
auch immer das ausspricht an den wilden
großen stücke wo jetzt wird es ein
bisschen kompliziert was ist denn eine
generation der hier haben sie eine idee
wie könnte man das verstehen
sie gibt es eine ganze sammelsurium an
zeitungsproduktion story die sind keine
zufälligen aus wachs oder monstrositäten
sind bestimmte regelmäßig gewächse die
zu absichten abdecken also abdecken des
technologie beginnt ziel die aber von
der anderen seite doch eben zuwenig
ähnliches mit dem gros stock auf dem sie
wachsen als miss und andere schmarotzer
pflanzen mit den bäumen worauf sie sich
finden haben
ich sehe nicht wie die verteidiger der
reformierten keime die entstehung
solcher vegetationen erklären wollen
aha das alles ein bisschen gegen das ist
doch wohl nicht so dass sie in allen s10
und blättern alle rosenstöcke der welt
auch über im eingewickelte keime für
unzählige schlaf annehmen die alle aufs
gerade wurde und gleichsam bloß auf
reserve in ihren ewigen schlaf hier
versenkt legen bis endlich das 1000 mal
1000 von ihnen durch den wohltätigen
stachel eines hinzufliegen philips aus
seinem kerker befreit und zur
entwicklung angetrieben wurde
jetzt kommt sie einmal dieser begriff
der pre formation
verstehen sie das
stehen wir doch
jetzt hatte ich eben dieses beispiel
diese müssten hier genau galveston
gebracht
was was macht denn eine galeristen
künstler ist weiß sie ganz genau
oder sie was ist das müssen wir auch mal
was noch die
wir gehen nun die bude
genau und das ist natürlich für die
damalige zeit total schwierig zu
erklären
diese ganz umstände und die hatten da
ganz interessante theorie dass also die
konnte neben und ich diese ganzen
feinheiten die bis heute kennt dies im
detail nachvollziehen das ist alles noch
recht spekulativ also dass nun die
sicherlich auch meinen detail den
märkten also wie diese gab es
tatsächlich operiert und wie die leute
es damals eben interpretiert aber die
norm sind auch diese reformation
versteht es geht jetzt also bestimmte
vegetationen und er spricht von solchen
vegetationen wie misteln und schneller
zu pflanzen wie misteln
genau
ich glaube es so lässig das sind diese
cordis symbiosen denn wir wissen dass
man die meint er aus reformations
theorie nicht so richtig leiden könnte
oder also praktisch sowas symbiotisches
also dass praktisch das könnte es eine
epigenetische zug sei das also etwas
erster stande kommt im nachhinein also
personal hat addition der mit den formen
nimmt und auch die lebensform und
plötzlich sehen wir die band zusammen
vielleicht in neulingen oder zumindest
die die die leben zusammen
diese symbolisieren oder wie auch immer
dies in einer symbiose begriff sie
kennen das ja dass dann plötzlich der
eine baum von dem anderen gewächsen auch
noch was bekommt etwas abzusagen
pilze ganz extrem erst kürzlich habe es
gehört wirklich das ganze pilzgeflecht
des waldes sind wir nicht mehr peters
geprägt unter der erdschicht hätten als
in der erde
dann könnte der ganze wald wächst was so
ein konstrukt internet der pilz ein
reaktion von traditionen des kindes
gefehlt und man das nicht hätte könnte
der wagen existieren also nährstoff
system ganz komplett kompensiert das
heißt diese verwobenheit lebensform
können wir nur ganz schlecht offen
dies erkläre ihm auf einem fonds
abziehen
es geht einfach um diese symbiose mit
inter subjektivität an verschicken diese
lebens
das fordern wir sind keine schon
vorhanden sein müsste
wir wissen aber ich frage sie sind ganz
einfach irgendein genau die auch die
fortpflanzung wirklich selbst
reproduzieren gewesen die gar kein
partner dazu brauchen gibt es auch einen
zeichentrickfilm jungs treten
und dieser bildung ständig wird oder
editiert
mit verschiedenen maßnahmen könnte er
diese bildungspolitik realisieren
wer so viel viel mehr
hier einfach lust sich zum beispiel
bäder gehören mich zu diesem 3
wenn ein baby diese erkennt und grund
eines der coolsten man braucht ja dass
arbeit die presse den herrlichsten
werkzeug das überleben zu sichern und
eigenem werkzeug die revolution zu
sichern kann ja aus oder sexuelle
fortpflanzung mich gesagt eine zusage
weil ja auch geld von pflanzungen einer
um das klar zu sein und haben daher
nicht wie man das gleiche raus aber das
könnte man ja auch dann unter dem
bildungsweg rechnen unter den
reproduktions lieb ist eine besondere
art der fortpflanzung
aber was ich sagen die sind
überlebenstrieb den finnen noch wichtig
also könnte der überlebenstrieb mit auf
den bildungs trieb zurückgeführt werden
also das war ja auch sehr punkte hat
nicht nur diese drei die situation an
diese produktion die generation als
manifestation des bildungs liegt könnte
man nicht auch noch überlebenstrieb als
zusätzliche manifestation des
bildungsträgers ansetzt
in frage
dort planen sollten dann ihr überleben
damit gerechtfertigt wurde mit
unterschiedlichen begraben will
verhindern dass wir als ich
aufgehört habe könnte es ja sein dass
genau richtig aber trotzdem ist noch da
und das würde darauf hindeuten dass es
dass mit dem bildungschip verboten ist
aber es ganz spannendes ganz spannendes
thema
wir lesen weiterhin gegen fürchte ich
nicht dass man das abgeschmackt finden
wäre anzunehmen dass in dem buch an den
saft der nacken sticht des insekts
heraustritt
durch die verbindung durch die zugleich
in ihnen gelebt eier und andere
veränderung einbildung streep erregt
werden könne
diesen saft zum schlafen also das ist
wohl diese das was die diese am besten
da macht das nennt man dann diesen
schlafen offensichtlich da wo eben diese
laufen oder was auch immer da dann sind
entsteht daraus sei dass diese lebens
kontext sowie hingegen nach lederwaren
befruchtung der erzeugungs saft durch
einen solchen trieb zum neuen tier oder
zu neue pflanze gebildet und dadurch die
eigentliche fortpflanzung bewirkt wird
eben diese ungleich allgemeinere ware
fortpflanzung ist es bei welcher bei der
sich der einfluss um die wirksamkeit des
bildungs liebes-aus unwiderleglich
sitzer alle erscheinungen über diesen
geschäfte dass ich zum beispiel nicht
sogleich nach der befruchtung sind immer
erst einige zeit nach her
die erste spur einige ausbildung die
zeug und saftes größer das aber nachher
diese einmal angefangene ausbildung und
das wachstum der neuen fahnenflucht auch
desto schneller fort
alle diese phänomene lassen sich ohne
den mindestens sagen
durch diesen bildung streep erklären
dass karl der scheinbar ein würfel die
mir selbst bei dieser untersuchung bei
gefallen sind
der sich nicht bei einer näheren
betrachtung sehr glücklich damit
vergleichen lassen
dann spielt jetzt in einem zeugnis saft
und das scheint mir recht einseitig dass
sein weil er vergisst dass zumindest bei
so dittmann noch die alt sind mit dazu
kommen
das ist eigentlich die alzette wenn ich
recht informiert wie viel mehr
informationen enthält als der st früher
als ich glaube dass das eine
konzentration auf die männliche geplant
zum ist das dach des sterbenden ist 70
moldawien seien aber eigentlich muss ja
immer beides zusammen kommt damit ein
wesen ein zeuge tier ziemlich entstehen
kann dass beide besucht haben wie sehen
sie es jetzt nochmal wie macht sich der
bildungs repliziert bemerkbar wo ist
überall zu sehen
es sagt hier das nach der befruchtung
nicht gleich danach sind das erst nach
einiger zeit sich der bildung streep
zeigt das doch kein beleg dafür aber
dass danach umso schneller geht
nächstes mal weiter
die misst das genau die missgeburten
selbst so nicht allein der bestimmtheit
diese streep ist kein eintrag das könnte
man ja fragen wie sieht's aus mit wesen
mit individuen die nicht richtig geformt
sind ja keine antrag da kein grund ist
warum er nicht wie jede andere kraft
durch zufällige nur so an gestört werden
eine abweichende richtung geben sollte
sind überaus sonnerat schon vielleicht
noch wenig bemerkte ähnlichkeit und dann
gibt's sogar dem triebel selbst ein
neues und sehr beträchtliches gewicht da
die abweichungen von der richtschnur von
einer wahrheit und so weiter ins
unendliche variieren können so scheint
es auf den ersten blick dass auch bei
bildung dem missgeburten diese
abweichungen von der regel nur die natur
hervorbringen organisierter körper eine
gleiche endlos und ganz zufällig
mannigfaltigkeit stattfinden müssen
also was ist jetzt ein einwand den
kräften sucht den 1
genau durch äußere musste also es liegt
nicht im betrieb dass er zu verformungen
für sondern es liegt im praktischen
äußerung exogen hat sich änderungen
geben ich ihnen herr behörden sind extra
viel von außen muss genau
allein bei anderen wird leuchten ergibt
sich viele dass eine gewohnheit würde
die gleichförmigkeit unter den meisten
monstrositäten herrscht und dass
folglich auch die usa die in diesen
fällen den verlust gibt die falsche
richtung geben dadurch monstrositäten
hervorbringen wer noch an sehr bestimmte
gesetze gebunden zu sein scheinen
während irgend gelegenheit gehabt hat
eine beträchtliche anzahl von missgeburt
miteinander zu vergleichen oder wer auch
nur die sonst freilich schale sterilen
komplettierten bücher davon mit einer
aufmerksamkeit durch gelernt hat in
katar frappante gleichheit nicht ganz
sein mit welcher diese oder jene art von
monstrosität sich immer selbst bis auf
kleinigkeiten ähnlich bleibt so dass die
stücke von so einer art alle wie aus
einer form gegossen schein aufhalte aber
ist dass gerade eine form von poesie tät
am häufigsten unter kindern eine andere
unternehmer an dritte fast muss
unterscheiden überhaupt mit allen tieren
geschäfte alle leichtes den missgeburt
sind ausgesetzt zu sein scheinen nicht
vorfinden
ganz interessant beschriebene und rosi
täter monster
ja als irgend wie sagte doch jetzt eine
verformung hat auf gewisse eigene
gesetze diese analogien
das heißt da müssen gewisse das heißt es
können nur bestimmte ursachen auf den
bildungsträgern wirklich auf erfahrungen
sind immer verformung der selben form zu
sagen was wiederum zeigen würde dass der
bildungs pc trägt ist oder sehr sehr
anfällig für äußere einflüsse so dass er
wenn es ein risiko sich nur begrenzt
verformen
das also dass das urgestein fähigkeit
beweisen die trägheit meisten dass er
ging es um sehr viel widerstand sich aus
seiner richtung bringen
wenn er aber aus der richtung gebracht
ist eine gewisse konstanz aufweist
immer genau das ist dieses exogene als
ist man könnte von einer gewissen
autonomie des bildungspolitisch sprechen
ihr punkt haben sie dann auch aus diesem
zitat diesem punkt dass es das aus sich
heraus ja genau also das geht schon
hervor am deutlichsten zeit für das hier
usa zufällig ursachen die zufälligkeit
noten ist wissen die notwendigkeit diese
trägheit im ganzen sind auch die
haustiere im monstrositäten weit mehr
unterworfen als die wilde alle waren
kritiken aber dennoch wiederum mehr als
die kaltblütigen und unter diesen werden
wieder fast bloß miss staltungen
einzelteile des kopfes und so weiter zu
weit angetroffen dagegen aber angeborene
doppelte beider und gliedmaßen so viel
ich mich ins sinne bei ihnen gehört sind
die entstehung der missgeburten setzt
eine sehr forcierte ganz widernatürliche
aber daher auch nie und nur wenn das
helfen sich von pflanzen die abweichung
des betriebs voraus anders ist es
hingegen mit der entstehung der spieler
und qualitäten unter den organisierten
körpern beschaffen als wobei die
ebenfalls in richtung dieses triebes auf
eine gelingt
der gewaltsame aber dafür desto tiefer
wurzeln schlagen dauerhaft auf die
nachkommen fortwirken weiße veranlasst
wird ja verstehen sie dass diese idee
könnte es ein bisschen spezifiziert wie
sie ist weil sie das heißt man durch
eine offenbar zwischen missbildungen wie
[Musik]
krank umfeld und kann schneller arbeiten
als ein mensch in zwei jahren begonnen
werden das verstehen als miss piggy
öffentlich gestaltungen und mit dem
essig oder zu essen bringen will muss
oder nicht weiß ich nicht
weiß und demonstrieren schon mal was
gehört hat was also extra hätten die
evolutionstheorie gefragt wer hat das
praktisch alleine nichts gefunden ist
eine selektion variation mutation
mutation und selektion mutation handelt
ist die frage kann man das schon als
missgeburt bezeichnet unterricht wenn
man zu 1000 jahre
heute
bestimmte machen wir bestimmten der
einen mittelfinger abzufangen sogar
allein in der höhle jetzt vor 1000
jahren voneinander affen der als müsste
wahrscheinlich wichtig genauso mann
tätlich gleich wofür diese veränderung
notwendig ist es kann also kann auch
eine ursache des bildungs seien ja also
hier vergleicht er jetzt eben die
verformungen die nicht gerichteten
verformungen der missstand oder
missgeburten sind mit eben den spielart
und varietät der organisieren ja auch so
verschieden sind ja aber die
offensichtlich als ist staltungen
aufzufassen
es ist immer dasselbe
[Musik]
genau ein mal eben durch äußere umstände
gewissermaßen aus dem aus der spur
gebracht könnte man sagen so ein
bisschen also aus dem gleichgewicht
gebracht und ein mal eben in seiner
ganzen feststellung sich den weg war
ganz spannend ob da wirklich qualitative
grenzen zu ziehen ist sollte nur sachen
die den bildungschip auf diese erbliche
weise erinnern können gehört vorzüglich
die mischung eines ungleichen zeugung
saftes die unter verschiedenen gattungen
eigentlich passt haben und qualität aber
wie unter projekts politisch unkorrekt
negern und weisen rouladen und ländle
hervorbringen auf eine ähnliche weise
scheint klima temperament usw
auf diesen krieg zu wirken und dadurch
national bildung familiengesicht usw zu
veranlassen
die merkwürdigsten auch von solchen
veränderungen sind abweichungen der
bildung abhängen der bildungs sind
zuverlässig die zu anfangs durch die
kunst aus gewohnheit landessitte uns
weiter veranlasst nach und nach haftet
gleichsam zu anderen natur und erblich
geworden sind das ist interessant es ist
epigenetik das ist jetzt lese ich habe
schon vor einigen jahren bei gelegenheit
an einer stelle im hippokrates erinnert
dass diese bemerkung bei untersuchungen
der menschen varietäten von nutzen sein
könnte und bin seitdem durch mancherlei
weiter bemerkung immer mehr darin
bestärkt das ist jetzt ganz klar die
genese das eben
schulz hat hier auch eine wii sagte dass
hier eine andere natur zum anderen natur
also neben sehr schön andere natur ich
bin auf eine zweite natur aber das wäre
es hätte ich die zweite natur ist die
kunden nicht von der anderem natur also
werde ich von unserer biologie die durch
gewissen kontext durch klima- und so
weiter und so fort
epigenetik verhindert werden das ist
ziemlich modern wenn ich diskutieren
also wie man das ist aber auch schon ein
bisschen so der punkt gewesen dass also
die nationalitäten mit ihrem sieg mit
den eigenheiten durch durch umstellung
auch kontingente umständen ein
zufälliger stimmen haben die chinesen
mussten nicht dort leben aber dies wäre
hätte auch ganz anders sein genauso wie
hier den europäern also völlig
konzentrieren ja also jetzt zimmer auf
fast schon durch möchten wir sind auch
am ende eine schule kommt gibt es jetzt
hier so ein bisschen so etwas ja so
etwas flapsige bemerkungen die
sogenannten bilden das ist jetzt so ein
bisschen so technologische
anthropologische beobachtung die wir
werden in der nächsten sitzung noch ein
bisschen drauf eingehen
jedenfalls wollen wir das doch zu ende
verfolgen die nächste sitzung dann aber
wollen wir uns mit einen ganz
bedeutenden schriftsteller und
philosophen auch und naturforscher
nämlich mit goethe fassen
der auch von dem zur bildung streep
spricht aber nur dann zählt er braucht
von einer formen lehre spricht sie
kennen alles diese uhr pflanzen dienen
kunden so also diese gen pflanzen kennen
sie der hat auch
das haben die formen lehre natur
entwickelt in dieser zeit hat er auch
eine lehre von licht entwickelt und
konkurrenz zum youtube hat er eben an
farben her entwickelt und wir wollen uns
unter wenn wir uns genau anschauen wie
sich goethes form begriff und trieb
begriff zudem breit und macht und herder
verhält die wir bereits kennen gelernt
haben dann wünsche ich ihnen jetzt noch
eine schöne woche und bis zum nächsten
sitzung